you all we're asked to come here for a
chance to find love your perfect match
let the games begin
out there with uh with Vanessa well
Vanessa has said in the past that you
guys doing these shows together has kind
of been like couples therapy was there
anything you were able to take away from
this show that you can kind of bring
back into your relationship with her
it's just that man Chester a lot when I
was down in Panama shooting for a month
it puts things quickly and perspectively
man I miss my wife I miss my kids if
they were all the same kind of shows I'd
probably get bored of it and they'd get
bored of me but uh this one's definitely
a little different which was why it was
cool I really want to win this challenge
because get in control of the board
means power will they create better
matches or will they create chaos one of
my favorite moments actually was in the
first episode and you didn't know what
the word cap meant what I wanted to do
with you real quick was throw some gen z
words at you and see if you know what
those mean okay all right I'm gonna feel
this I'm telling you right now to feel
this already good okay the first one is
chugi it's um a loogie that's made from
chocolate a chocolate Lugia chugi I have
no clue okay almost almost no it just
means very uncool okay is uncool all
right well I'm choosing you right now
for sure okay
um the next one is called simp just
assuming that's like short for simple
you're just simple oh no that would make
sense but no it just means someone that
does way too much for someone they're
trying to impress all right and the last
one is sheesh I have no
sounds like you're saying quiche which
is like a a breakfast pie made of egg so
I'll go with that
all right yeah she's just like someone's
looking really good you know you see
you're going out for a dinner night with
Vanessa she's looking really good you go
sheesh you know I'm turning 50 this year
and I've never felt more like I should
be turning 50 this year than I do right
now because I have no clue what these
kids would talk about anymore
[Music]